in
tenin this is going to represent UK's
spine her head's at the top here it
comes forward and usually what people
think
is that it's going to go like this in
some way so sometimes you have some ukas
that will slide
under okay and then sometimes you have
ukas like if this had a hinge here and
this top part goes like this they Bend
backwards okay at at the back and then
they go B they go backwards into the
back breakfall but either way uh if we
just look at the head
area uh it's going that way which in our
Dojo is east and then the head is
brought West okay in either way whether
the feet keep going or whether it bends
here and then they do the step back back
break fall whatever none of that stuff
is what we want to do because they're
coming from west to east and we pushing
that head back from east to west so
that's a y young Clash so if uh this is
where the heaven arm would be what we
want to do
instead is we know for the head to
go
from back to West then it has to be
brought on that Circle the kagay circle
so that it's forward inertia is
maintained you you have to do that in
every technique any technique where
there's a back breakfall there's this
little yield here um I've come to this
is a yid yield but I've come to actually
uh uh sometimes referred to it as o
sense y yield because this is what he
does all the time okay you're going to
go this way you make that little Loop
and now you come this
way then your hip goes in here and this
part starts to now ful them around this
way and as the feet are
lifting the head is getting light so the
head we know is going down but I'm not
actually throwing it down it's more I
pick the feet up and I help pick the
feet up by moving the head this way and
then eventually that head Falls over on
this side head is going forward it's
going to do that
c on the head now the forward inertia is
going rearward okay then I got to get
weight off the feet and so I bring the
head this way with my hip over here the
head goes this way the feet go that way
and the feet start to lower the head and
the guy falls down okay just around
sh